gamespot tech editor Jimmy thing here
and we have a ps4 Pro that we're gonna
unbox for you so let's get into it
so inside the box we have a Quick Start
Guide to start you off after that the
next thing we have is the console itself
which has some cardboard pieces to hold
it up on the side
[Music]
definitely a lot heavier than the
original ps4 gonna go ahead and give
that a couple spins for you this is at
the front of the ps4 Pro here another
one of the sides and then you got some
ports on the back and we have a
cardboard box here with I assume all the
cables and power cables and HDMI cables
and whatnot so here you have a USB cable
this is for like the controller charging
the controller you have the power cable
you have earbuds you have the
PlayStation controller and I assume this
is the newer one with the little cut up
cutout LED that came by the ps4 slim as
well
and then finally you have the HDMI cable
and this is going to be an HDMI 2.0
cable which you'll need to take
advantage of HDR and 4k the PlayStation
4 Pro is the largest PlayStation 4 and
to compare we've put all three models on
the table below you here and there you
have it that's everything inside the ps4
PO box for more tech coverage head on
over to GameSpot comm and subscribe to
our YouTube channel
[Music]